at that point it looks quite likely to
drop off um
okay levon he blocks the attack of one
of the white rooks
um but he's shaking his head um oh but
here's mine
magnus carlson missed it he could have
won a rook in one move
um okay anyway yeah i think we have to
bring up the ball to show that moment
that was
so dramatic um in this position um
magnus carlsen he did miss an
opportunity levon aronian's last move
bringing the rook across one square
magnus the first thing we teach
beginners actually the first thing we
should always look for are checks and
captures
he could have played this move pushing
his pawn forward giving check to the
black king
it looks like a sacrifice this pawn can
be taken but he's opened up
a line against the undefended black rook
and this is what we mean
by the trigger happy hand because i'm
sure the hand just made the move
and then afterwards i think i saw the
slight shake from magnus where he
realized oh wow and we saw it on the bar
as well it was completely winning for
magnus and then
one move later missed it it's a draw
well
the bar is saying it's a draw can magnus
still win this game